you're imperfect and you're wired for
struggle but you are worthy of love and
belonging
that's our job yes you are it's been 10
years since best-selling author and
researcher brene brown gave that ted
talk which has now been viewed almost
50 million times you go brene brown it's
also celebrating the
10th anniversary of her best-selling
book it's called the gifts of
imperfection let go of who you think
you're supposed to be
and embrace who you are don't we know
people like that to commemorate it
she's releasing a special edition you
could say with a new preface
on how people can live a wholehearted
life that's what she calls it during
these
challenging times renee brown joins us
this morning renee brown good to see you
i love the phrase nice to see you too
i'm so glad you're here i love the
phrase
wholehearted life because i'm wondering
about i read it over the weekend i have
to say renee the words really stand up
they still hold today
what have you learned in the last 10
years because i thought it was
interesting that you said we all have a
journey of
head work and heart work and you did the
head work but you didn't
you didn't feel you had done the hard
work so what did you learn what have you
learned
i think the biggest two learnings for me
over the past decade have been
one taking the work in this book and
putting it into practice is
way more difficult than i thought and
two it is
actually way more worth it than i
thought so it is
you know it's tough to wake up every
morning especially in this world and
make
a commitment to not betray yourself for
other people
not to disappoint them not to make them
angry
to take a stand that's different it's
it's that's a hard daily practice
and if it's not a daily practice it
really doesn't mean anything
you said that wholehearted living is not
just one thing that it really is a
process
what do you mean by that wholehearted
living you have courage compassion and
connection
you said it's a process not just one
thing one time
i think you know this was the first time
that my data
led me to a catastrophe in my own life
and so
i thought if you knew if you knew how
these things worked
it would be enough but what we know is
not enough it's
it's who we are and how we show up so
it's great that you know these things
are you practicing them
every day especially when you feel
backed into an emotional corner or you
feel less than
these are not to-do list items which i
am very fond of checking off in my life
um these are practices and sometimes
we're great and sometimes we just
blow it and you have to get back up and
do it again last time you were here the
pandemic was starting and i wrote down
what you said because
we're all learning how to settle into a
new normal while grieving the loss of
normal
now you say we're all getting through
this and you hope that we don't go back
to normal
what do you mean
i think the combination you know
everyone said in the beginning you know
the
the the pandemic the virus doesn't
discriminate and i thought yeah the
virus doesn't discriminate but
americans discriminate and so what we
have seen
over the past six months is the
over-representation
in sick people and dying people in
communities
around race and around poverty and
i think the combination of the pandemic
with
an a long overdue and ongoing racial
reckoning
i don't want to go back to the way it
was so i think and i i think most people
don't
we want something better and we deserve
something better and
any kind of pandemic or crisis really
highlights the fault lines in a country
in a family in a community and we need
to build for what's next
not build back for where we were because
where we were
served a few of us at the expense of
others yeah i've heard you say i'm not
here to be right i'm here to get it
right
yeah yeah that's my uh that's my
personal motto especially when i'm
having difficult conversations around
race gender
orientation work you know
we you know even our hard wiring says
hey listen when you're pushed to the
edge and you're
you know you feel accused or you feel
put down fight back and so the thing i
try to tell myself as a hack is look i'm
not here to be right to prove that i'm
right
i'm here to get it right be quiet let
others lead
learn and learn there's so many
beautiful things about you brene but
part of it is that you are so open and
show sharing about your life you write
in the book about seeing a therapist i
thought
renee brown goes to therapist people go
to you for therapy
but you say that you learn more than you
teach
yeah i'm no one comes to me for therapy
for sure i am not a therapist
um i'm i trained with a bunch of people
who went that route and i went the
research route
um yes i've had a therapist i mean i
think they're just two camps of people
people who are struggling and don't get
help and people who are struggling and
do get help
i want to be in the struggling and get
help camp
we're not supposed to do this alone we
were never meant to do this alone
we're not wired that way we're supposed
to lean into each other
and congratulations is in order because
this time
you get to do the audible of this book
you didn't get to you didn't you didn't
get to you get to do the audio of the
book rather
because last time you didn't get to do
the audio because they thought uh we
need to get a real reader
right yeah i think that's okay so that
was exciting because
i never read it but i you know i never
read it out loud and i remember reading
it and
one of the things that that our
community said to us is
give us a hardback read the audiobook do
not change the stories just
update this the front or something and
so telling these stories especially the
parenting struggles
and the struggles in my marriage um
it's so funny because the kids are 10
years older but the struggles
are better but they're still there i
mean you know perfectionism dies hard
yep well yeah it really does thank you
for being a great researcher and a
really great storyteller and thank you
for sharing
thank you for sharing we learn a lot
from you thanks for having me thanks a
lot
the 10th anniversary edition of the
gifts of imperfection
is available today wherever you like to
buy your books